nobody gets it nothing you think matters
matters this isn't special this is
happening infinite times across infinite
realities including this yes which is
not to say that subjectively it wasn't
funny are you going to stay there's
infinite timelines Morty why would I
stay in the one where I trashed the
white house became an enemy of America
and the lowest status character and my
idiot family because of the fart hey
everybody this is gonna be my season
three finale season four Q&A just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episodes yet the really cool news
that just dropped is that Rick and Morty
is now the all-time highest viewed
series on Adult Swim and it is now the
leading comedy amongst people ages 18 to
45 more people are watching Rick and
Morty that are watching The Simpsons or
traditional Network animation like it's
crushing everything else so if you ever
wondered if they were gonna do more Rick
and Morty that is a clear indicator that
they are doubling down i really hope
that justin roiland and dan harmon were
able to use that information when they
were renegotiating their contracts to
try and get some more money I mean if
your series is blowing up you deserve to
be paid more money but here we go first
question and Trax asks maybe why episode
10 didn't feel really like a season
finales because 14 would have been the
end and they just added the after the
credits scene well they actually
probably figured out they were only
gonna do ten episodes in the middle of
production so I think it was planned
that way at least midway through the
season when I say that I'm talking about
when they were writing the scripts like
when they sense that it was taking a lot
longer they're like okay we can only
handle 10 episodes this season so that's
probably when they picked their endpoint
and why they chose to do mr. poopy
butthole just because of the big delay
between season 2 and season 3 next one
crazy monkey ass there was a scene in
the trailer for season three with two
summers but it never showed up this
season what happened well not every
scene from those intros each season
makes it into the actual season or
sometimes they get deleted the animatic
stage like they intended to put it in
but then it gets cut out I'll do a video
and then
next week or so for all the deleted
scenes going back to season 1 next one
is Eva's do you think that there'll be
another interdimensional cable episode
maybe in which all them are aware
they're characters of a TV show
so you just mean like a really meta
episode actually the interdimensional
cable thing is probably something
they'll never try again or at least not
in the way that they've done it before
the whole idea with more teas mind
blowers is the writer who pitched it
said that he pitched it trying to do
another interdimensional cable to the
network they agreed to it as it was this
way so they might have actually shot
down then doing interdimensional cable
again or maybe the writers decided they
didn't want to beat that idea to death
but they'll continue to do anthology
episodes like that where you jump
through a bunch of different stories
within a single episode and I don't know
that we'd ever get an episode where
everybody figured out they're in a TV
episode I think Jerry deserves to be the
dumbest character for the rest of the
series run 97 more years of Jerry being
dumb as rocks maybe once Morty becomes
fully actualized if that ever ends up
happening on the show that's when he'd
figure out he was inside a TV show whole
bunch of evil Morty questions to Jace
asks what if evil Morty isn't evil well
so I think the idea behind that is that
nobody really thinks of themself as evil
like Rick does some evil seeming things
but technically he's not an evil
character I think part of the idea of
the name evil Morty is a parody itself
of evil characters and television shows
like the idea of hammer Morty or fly
fishing Rick like it's utterly
ridiculous like you're meant to laugh at
the name and at the character separately
at the same time next one
Jordan asks do you think that evil Morty
Tammy and Phoenix person will form an
alliance if so how would that work
what would their end game be well I
think the idea is that evil Morty is a
master at playing other people so I
think he just tried to play on the idea
of Tammy and Phoenix person trying to
get Rick's portal technology I've said
it before but I think that if they do go
after Rick their goals will be a little
bit different like they wanted his
portal technology before but if evil
Morty has access to that already he
could offer it to them but they'd also
have to be another reason for Tammy to
want to take Rick down so evil Morty
would have to manipulate her into
thinking that c-137 Rick was a threat
because he wants to take Phoenix person
away from her
they'd have to play on her emotions like
it depends on how she really feels about
Phoenix person
a lot of that's just speculation I think
when the characters pop back up they'll
pop back up in separate stories that are
unrelated from each other next question
and this is a good one
Luke asks do you think that Tammy and
Morty are related in some sort of way
like there's some sort of resemblance
between them like a female version of
Morty who's created a plan to use
birdperson to kill our main characters
and she hates the way that Rick treats
Morty's so basically you're asking if
Tammy is a version of Morty in some
twist on evil Morty I don't think that's
the case but I do like the idea that she
has a personal vendetta against Rick if
Yuri watch a lot of the earlier scenes
from season two with Tammy when she's
first getting with birdperson
they're really funny but she's just
meant to be that awful girlfriend
character they co-op's your friend like
Rick really loves bird person but now
he's spending all of his time with Tammy
so Rick hates Tammy the girlfriend but
then the series turns it into a more of
a literal thing where she really becomes
evil and actually kills and then
resurrects bird person so whereas she
was like this really big annoying
character before now she's a legit
threat to Rick and before those
characters can move forward Rick has to
learn that Phoenix person is still alive
and so far we've seen no indication of
that next one this is another good one
Bryan asks what if mr. poopy butthole is
controlled by evil Morty and he's
gathering info on Rick like you're
saying and all those pictures that we
see on is well I don't think that's the
case either but I do love the idea of
evil Morty's slowly controlling people
around Rick the early speculation was is
that his ultimate plan is to turn
everyone against Rick like right now he
called himself out is the lowest status
person in the family and if evil Morty
really wanted to get a trick he'd have
to turn arm Morty against him along with
the rest of his family like he could
have killed them all at the end of the
episode wipe the slate clean and gone to
a different reality but the sheer fact
that he puts up with all their
at the end of the episode proves that he
loves them next one's FSP asks do you
think that scary Terry the devil and
Jaguar will return no I'm not expecting
them to return maybe in pictures in the
background or like really small Easter
eggs but I think that was part of the
idea with the end tag with Jaguar like
that was the joke that he would come
back he's always helping them out
[Music]
who who was that Rick that Morty is why
you don't go to therapy
next one Jessica asks when do you think
that Morty will try the legendary
Szechuan sauce
that's a good question with all the
real-life Szechuan sauce stuff that's
been happening I don't know if they'd
ever get super literal with it inside
the TV show the idea that Morty would
taste something that Rick is willing to
wait ninety seven years to get so just
because of the extreme way they played
that joke at the end I'm not expecting
them to bring that back but there might
be some rappers in a trash can or
something in the background just some
sort of visual reference that there was
some Szechuan sauce at some point
between seasons next one Roger asks
what's the deal with Rick being afraid
of pirates but also making Pirates of
the pancreas in the holiday episode I
think that was actually mostly part of
that Wikipedia joke like the government
got other information from him from that
and most of it was false with a few
exceptions I he should he'd get really
philosophical about it and say that Rick
is trying to express his fears in some
physical form but really I think that
was more of a Wikipedia joke and not
meant to be connected to that season one
joke so you can treat that as cannon if
you want or you can just treat it as a
one-off funny thing next one Daniel asks
what would you do if you made a Rick and
Morty an episode what would it be it
would probably just be a mythology
episode I probably wouldn't get too
complicated I'm not an animator
obviously I don't have those skills so I
would probably just stick to evil Morty
and simple stuff like that sometimes you
don't realize how hard like Morty's mind
blowers are but they can be fun because
you don't have to write like an entire
20 minute story that ends up being a
whole bunch of pages for a little
one-off jokes like there were some
really great brief moments and they were
really only pieces of stories without
having to go super deep on it young man
come here little boy tell Daphne to run
a $1.99 on a possible do little but next
one muffin cat asks what about season
four are you most excited about I would
say probably the mythology stuff just
like the big hanging story threads that
they didn't wrap up at the end of the
season like hey we're totally not gonna
tell you what happened to evil Morty at
the end of that episode the other real
big thing that I loved about this season
was the couple of times that I was just
absolutely blown away with surprise like
Morty's memory of getting engaged to mr.
poopy butthole something so ridiculous
that you never
have thought that they would ever do
something like that in a million years
that was more surprising to me than evil
Morty but people have been wondering
about evil Morty
since that season one episode what is he
doing but how many of you have actually
wondered about Morty getting engaged to
mr. poopy butthole you can just hear the
sound of everybody everywhere falling
out of their chair laughing but thank
you so much for submitting questions
these are always a ton of fun to do I
will keep doing Rick and Morty Q&A is
every once in a while if you guys want
me to but that's in addition to the
regular bonus videos I'll be doing so
they'll be new Rick and Morty on Friday
maybe on Saturday too and then next week
so just leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below but
there's a new round of that Zen monkey
studios merch giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from the last video Jimmy
plays please private message me so I can
get your contact details you can click
here for my season 4 video and you can
click here for the new flash trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]